What are Portswiga people like? In a word, they are exceptional, but exceptional across
a broad range of attributes. Everyone is hired to do a certain job, whether it's engineers,
researchers, writers, designers, whatever it is. They need to be A-team players in their role.
We work on some of the most interesting and difficult problems that there are,
and we aim to do that work to an exceptional standard. So, we need people who are extremely
good at what they do. But that is only the start, and really it's a small part of the overall
qualities that we look for in our people. Because our culture and our ways of working are so important
to us, we look for many other personal attributes which are common to every position. Fundamentally,
Portswiga people are nice to each other. They are naturally helpful and altruistic. They're low ego.
They think more about their own limitations and development needs than about all the things
they're brilliant at. One of the things that our new joiners often comment on is that everyone they
meet is not only happy, but also really nice. Our work is highly collaborative, and we look for people
with great communication skills and also emotional intelligence. Being aware of our own emotions and
able to control them, adapting our communication style to other personality types, these really are
superpowers that make our whole team so effective. We look for people who bring energy and can do to
everything. People who thrive on learning new things and who love a new challenge. People who can
continue growing and naturally take a lead in areas where they're able to. We're well aware that
we set a high bar in our recruitment. Many people who look at Portswiga can find themselves thinking,
I won't be good enough. To that, I would say that many of our successful candidates, and quite possibly
our ideal candidates, are people who don't realise just how good they are. To be honest, we'll take them
any day over someone who swaggers in thinking they're going to walk it. So if you think that Portswiga
will be a good place for you, then please do get in touch. Let us worry about whether you're a good fit for us.